exactamente dos años después del
lanzamiento del primer juego se estrenó
lo que sería para muchos el mejor juego
de la saga uno que mejoraría todos los
aspectos del juego anterior y nos
demostraría que no todas las secuelas
son malas
gears of war 2 con más hombres mamá dos
más sangre y menos carnes
[Música]
este es uno de esos extraños casos en
donde la secuela logra superar al
original con mejores gráficos una
historia mejor y más profunda y mejor
gameplay pues sí es verdad que el primer
juego fue muy bueno pero por favor aquí
matamos a un [ __ ] gusano gigante desde
adentro
gears of war 2 supo cómo aprovechar todo
lo que su predecesor hizo bien dándonos
un gran juego con muchos momentos de
icónicos de la saga y uno de los juegos
más memorables así que vamos a honrar
este gran juego bien algunos de sus
secretos y datos más curiosos
vamos a ver 30 curiosidades secretos y
detalles de gears of war 2
[Música]
el mundo nos corresponde por fin
un año
el equipo de epic games tuvo mucha
confianza en el éxito del primer juego
ya que comenzaron a desarrollar kirk
software 2 antes de la salida del primer
juego junto con gears of war 4 este es
el único juego en donde a lo largo de la
campaña no aparece ningún berserker las
granadas de tinta fueron incluidas por
primera vez en este juego pero si pones
atención verás que no son simples armas
ya que estas granadas están hechas con
las crías de los demás ist recuerdas la
parte en la que desde los tejados tienes
que matar un bruma con morteros bueno
usando un glitch podemos hacer que don
baje los tejados y camine por la calle y
se enfrente con el bruma uno para uno
sin camiseta y qué vas a hacer que vas a
hacer según la historia del juego antes
de que es curse fuera un líder militar
para los locos
él era un sumo sacerdote y era
considerado como la figura religiosa más
alta de los locos para ellos es por ser
el equivalente a lo que es el papá para
los humanos
este es el diseño inicial de escorts que
tenía una sierra pegada a el brazo pero
desafortunadamente este diseño se
descartó durante la producción
este juego incluyó por primera vez un
par de mecánicas a la saga
se convertirían en algo icónico lakers
software como poder usar a sus enemigos
caídos como escudo en los duelos de
sierras pero eso no fue todo lo que el
juego incluyó pues en este título fue la
primera vez que se incluyó el modo horda
el diseño detalle está inspirado en los
maoríes de nueva zelanda lo cual se
puede evidenciar mayormente por los
tatuajes que les rodean el cuerpo epic
games creó a está ahí con un personaje
que tenía como objetivo mostrar la
religión y su diversidad en el universo
del juego ya que hasta ese momento no
habían tenido un personaje que fuera
particularmente religioso durante el
desarrollo del juego se suponía que está
y debía morir lanzándose a sí mismo por
un acantilado
pero cliff bleszinski decidió cambiar la
escena de su muerte pues no le parecía
lo suficientemente brutal por lo que
prefirió dejar la escena de la escopeta
la visión de coleccionista de kirk
software 2 trae una caja metálica para
el juego un libro de ilustraciones un
dividido el detrás de escenas de la
creación del juego y una foto de don y
mariah idéntica a la que se ve en el
juego
en el mapa estación tairo si al comenzar
el juego le disparas a una señal de
advertencia la próxima vez que pase el
tren podemos ver a marcus como un
pequeño histérico
[Música]
en la escena final del gears of war
original luego a soltar la bomba de masa
ligera aparece scores montado en su by
dra pero en este juego su diseño es muy
distinto siendo el de un locus con capa
esto se debe a que en ese momento no
habían creado el diseño final de escorts
estos son los diseños descartados de la
hidra o el uber river durante el
capítulo 4 cuando estamos en la guarida
de los locos en varios lugares podemos
encontrarnos unas extrañas esferas que
parecen ojos que no seguirán a donde
vayamos según sus creadores el diseño
final de score está basado en el
depredador
stratton es un personaje secundario en
gears of war 3 que nos acompañará por
gran parte del juego pero sabías que
esta no es la primera aparición de james
la primera vez que hayáis mencionado es
en gears of war 2 cuando marcus y dom
llegan a la hondonada y mediante la
radio podemos oír a james quien habla
brevemente con marcus
[Música]
también a ti y marco gracias
en el multijugador ubicar el mapa
canales existe un curioso secreto pues
si buscas por todo el lugar y le
disparas a un muro en específico
comenzará a destruirse revelando poco a
poco lo que parece ser un rostro muchos
piensan que es la figura de un alien o
que puede ser la figura de maría
santiago la esposa de dom pero nunca se
confirmó que es esta extraña figura la
historia de madrid on tiene un gran
protagonismo en este juego siendo además
el primer juego en donde sabemos acerca
de maría y dónde podemos verla pero ella
fue mencionada mucho antes de una manera
bastante sutil en el kirk software
original cuando el escuadrón delta llega
al campamento de los refugiados aquí
podemos oír que mientras don y franklin
están conversando éste le dice no hay
noticias de la señora amigo si yo viera
al rey te lo diría refiriéndose a mariah
pues doble pidió hace tiempo que le
ayudará a encontrarla esto es bastante
sorprendente pues ya desde el primer
juego y sin saberse triunfaría ya nos
están planteando sutilmente una secuela
lo que quiere decir que piquen siempre
tuvo fe en que lograrían hacer una
segunda parte
para la creación de este juego los
desarrolladores querían que tuviera una
historia mucho más profunda que el juego
anterior y para conseguirlo contrataron
al escritorio su ortega quien era
conocido por trabajar en varios cómics
de batman spiderman e incluso un par de
novelas de kirk software ortega fue uno
de los escritores del juego pero
pensante que creó una gran historia lo
más destacable acerca de esto es que fue
ortega junto a cliff bleszinski quienes
le dieron forma a la bella y trágica
historia de dom y mariah de la que todos
tenemos que estar de acuerdo en que es
una de las mejores partes del juego y se
la debemos a estos dos
[Música]
cuando tome y marcus estará a punto de
bajar a la hondonada de la nada aparece
scores quien pelea con dice y luego con
time pero antes de que pudiéramos ver
cómo termina la pelea la cápsula se
cierra luego de esto talles derrotado y
capturado pero extrañamente más adelante
en el juego se ve a ti sí sano y salvo
esto se nos explica en uno de los cómics
del juego en donde se nos muestra que
tie le dijo a dice que escapara mientras
él se quedaba peleando uno a uno con
scores la idea que posees corts en este
juego es de la misma especie de la que
vimos en manos de uconn en gears tactics
durante el acto 4 en la guardia de los
locos podemos encontrar un histeria a
modo de una caja que al romperla nos
revelará una tostadora locust
el gusano que vemos y matamos en el
juego realmente tiene cientos de años
este gusano es un ser prehistórico que
los locos aprendieron a controlar y hace
parte de un grupo de tres gusanos de la
misma especie que los locos adoraban
como dioses conocidos como la trinidad
de los gusanos siendo caemos en gears of
war 2 el último que quedaba con vida
estos gusanos representaban la religión
para los locos ahora no lo sé incluso
creando amuletos en su honor como el
símbolo de la trinidad de los gusanos
que encontramos más adelante en el juego
en los primeros años de la guerra locus
cuando la lancer clásica aún no existía
eso no tenían la lanza retro muchos de
los soldados de la cocc se quejan porque
la bayoneta de la lanza retro ya no
penetraba la armadura de los locust así
que se comenzó a trabajar en un nuevo
modelo de la lanza pero la idea de
agregar la sierra se obtuvo realmente
gracias a tal pues durante una batalla
cuando marcus estaba peleando contra un
dron y no podía alcanzar ninguna de sus
armas tie tomó una sierra y partió a el
locus a la mitad
salvando hacia marcus luego de esto está
él le dijo a marcus que el mundo está
lleno de armas esperando a ser
descubiertas porque dejó pensando a
marcus así que luego cuando ve a su
padre el echo
lo que pasó y le recomendó que agregara
algo parecido a un arma creando así la
clásica lancer
uno de los mejores intereses del juego
tiene inspiración en bici pues en el
capítulo 3 del acto 1 cuando estamos a
bordo de las perforadoras si pones
atención al camino podrás encontrar tres
sombreros en distintos lugares si les
disparamos a los tres haremos que todos
los personajes ahora tengan sombreros
iguales a el de diez y si incluso esta
cosa
cuando estamos en la hondonada y
encontramos la excavadora junto a dom y
carmen donde tiene uno de los diálogos
más divertidos del juego y todo para
[ __ ] a carmen pues en la escena en
donde encendemos la excavadora mientras
dom y carmen hablan doble recuerda a su
hermano y la manera en la que un
francotirador lo mató en el primer juego
amigo hay polvo por todas partes
ahora no tendría tanto
pero entonces
bueno
en un detrás de cámaras o la creación
del juego cliff bleszinski nos reveló
una escena eliminada del juego pues
originalmente luego de la escena de la
muerte de maría cuando estamos a punto
de filtrar nos en el nexus se suponía
que el juego nos diera la opción de
entrar disparando a todo el mundo como
sea en el juego original o entrar
sigilosamente disfrazados de locos para
pasar desapercibidos lo cual
lastimosamente fue eliminado de la
versión original del juego dejando
únicamente la ruta en donde matamos a
todo el mundo
depredador silencioso mismo las
curiosamente esta cena fue luego agregar
al juego como contenido descargable si
esperamos a que todos los créditos
terminen al final de todo podremos
escuchar a adam phoenix el padre de
marcus preparándonos para el inminente
seguir software 3 pues nos advierte que
esto no ha acabado que hemos librado un
mal peor sobre la humanidad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
afortunadamente para personas como yo la
saga de kirk software es de esos tipos
de juegos que tienen un montón de datos
curiosos y este juego no es para nada la
excepción así que espero que te hayan
gustado todos estos datos si quieres ver
más datos curiosos y secretos de otros
videojuegos al final te dejo un par de
vídeos que sé que te encantará hasta la
próxima
[Música]